bene da tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo video su rocket league
il gioco con le macchinine dove siamo
certi uno step non si sa come ma le
vinciamo l'importante è partecipare e
arrivare a 100 in questo mi hanno sempre
spiegato anche da bambino volete vivido
buona visione
l'ex co guarda che bravo che potrà ampi
che l'ho tolta l'ho tolta io perché
adesso questo canale lo porto alle
stelle anche al clan gente guardate non
si spegne il monito a 35 nodi
non vale è distratto palo tra il mio
padre di questa scritta senza far casini
ma non ai gol fatto per e incredibile
come ha schiacciato il manto dall'altra
c'è il gol è automatico sì sì è proprio
fatto apposta
no sono scarso però come noi ok
bellissimo anche col ma che applica
affatto
ma non si sa mai in vent'anni sto flick
mania di talché ok ok sì sì perché vedi
che sono francese jacquelin free ma
chiama lapin john levi che non so cosa
voglia dire mai la parata
grazie per aver no e lui è stato furbo a
ma io la vulcan raga ma cacchio sto
usando con lama che soltanto un'altra
macchina è mamma ha fatto il 22 soltanto
la mia vulcan di una volta ha provato
anche lui il flick incredibile mai a
male che male poteva essere un gol
meraviglioso ma in ciò non è vero però
fu luogo
ma dai ma perché no no non ci credo non
ci posso credere
mamma mia mamma mia come li punisce favi
la tiene lì la pinto le best perché gara
sembrava che ci fosse il follo allora
lui andata invece 9 tutto calcolato io
io seguo segue anche lui è la palla è
rimbalzata come se non esistessi veniva
bello ben fatto fortissimo sul muro si
stava involando ma me ne sbatto lapin
dalle best ok non so se riesco a
toglierla vediamo riesco bene con no non
esageriamo però lei invece esageriamo
non è che io l'ho sconcentrato perché
era talmente lento che ha detto eh vabbè
dai mi dimentico come si para vado io
erroraccio della pin gialle 30 e strano
continua a dirlo perché non capito cosa
vuol dire anche voli prima era così ok
aia che male fa e va beh allora niente
per molto poco buono
qualunque cosa voglia dire vai bravo e
non ci arriva e non ci arriva signore ha
vinto 4 a 1 14 gol del five 23 20
secondi trenta minuti resta però va bene
io posso parlare italiano posso fare i
gol decidi scegli una delle due guerre
esigente più fischi gol va bene sei
contento che scegliesti questo non solo
a te facendo a casa io aspettavo di
controllarsi che cosa vuol dire mano
vampata 2010 6 belli
vengo al meritato ha meritato di che un
bel gol
signori prendete esempio da questo
ragazzo guardate il controllo il
contrasto al telefono bellissimo gol del
favi che prende la traversa al palo alla
riga per accogliere meglio e loro
insegnanti loro stavano arrivando ma con
quel attraversato il diritto e
continuate a giocare per giunta senza
che loro avevano finito
sono convinto di questo
ok viene a questo è il 54
perché lì in balsa la che poi fallì e
non hanno preso medaglia ma van fatto lo
sapeva lui che mi dovevano fare io
faccio un rientro tipo così che non si
aspetta nessuno invece si vuole andare
subito tolgo no dai non può avere turbo
per tutto niente tutto per tutto ogni
lato gliela toglie la fortissimo lo
tolgo io lui lo demonizza di nuovo
poverino mai saltato subito barbato che
si passa non tirando joystick allo
schermo tori questo caso e mi spiace mi
spiace mi spiace arrivederci a rivedere
il cipe contengono nice
ok ok va bene cacchio avuto e non era
male per nulla ma che l'ha apprezzato
anche lui e non avevo turbo perché ho
provato a tenerlo al massimo
debutto nella invece sai forse sì per
era era inaspettata ti seguo anche lui
sta seguendo
ok allora attivato vado non vado
ho fatto una ct metto anch'io academy e
sono un gol sono state tranquilli per
fortuna
scusami nova vampata d'amico davanti
metà buono bella bella bella bella bella
bella bella bella
dai dai dai va bene cosa c'è allora
turbo traversa lo stesso traversa il
favi traversa lo stesso posso
arrabbiarmi ok grazie ma la messa è
stato onesto lui capito la testa perché
ha visto le attraversano
adesso gliela do perché non mi sembra
giusto ecco se tutti giocassero così
saremmo su persone che non lo siamo
niente lo manca non ci basta vabbè ma
c'è dai però ma che gioco è ma perché
deve entrare per dove sta scritto che
deve entrare per forza come ha fatto
palo
qualcosa c'è ma guarda io carica l'altro
dice veramente incredibile mancata di
millimetro
eccolo è lui nostra seguendo ma tanto
dall'alto non segni quindi preferisco
toglierlo raccolto 1 prato palo certo
noi non siamo gli avversari perfetto
guardare che fa attraverso pranzo col
gol che non va in questo server quanti
grande esclusa è mancato il gol in due
minuti e mezzo va bene praticamente si
può andare male vi importa a nessuno
stare importo che hanno ma non è male
molto bello buono
meno male la settimana minimamente lui
ma neanche io così me lo aspettavo
tito in porta il politico che quello la
porta sul muro vuole fare robe ok ok
allora ancora aveva i siti tanto più che
tutto storto
io non lo turba venivano qua che sta
perdendo un sacco di tempo per sta cosa
ok sono a toglierla bravissimo bravo a
tina piccolo è loro no lo più forza
invece intenzione però nella prevenzione
esplosa arrivo mou che rischiano fatto
hanno avuto a che brutto stocco santa
casa malissimo lerner che soppressi di
attenzione
oltre ai 10 secondi adatta vado al
intoccata occhio tira lasciamo perdere
tempo gigi chi gli ha chiesto come
giochiamo e l'altro gioco va bene
ragazzi miei questo la video di rocket
league con lo staff one e spero che vi
sia piaciuto anche today
iscrivetevi lasciato un mi piace un
commentino e noi ci siamo
[Musica]